ich war sehr auf der Zehner als ich
folgendes Statement von den Auftritt von
unser Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz gesehen
habe
also zunächst mal toll dass sie eine
Bäckerei haben
und ich hoffe dass wir mit dem was jetzt
beschlossen ist und dem was wir jetzt
Morgen auf den Weg bringen werden auch
die Grundlagen dafür geschaffen werden
dass sie mit den furchtbar hohen
Energiepreisen umgehen können neulich
kam jemand zu mir sagte Herr Scholz ich
habe meinen Elektroofen gerade auf ein
Gasofen umgestellt und habe ich wusste
ich gar nicht wie traurig ich gucken
sollte
also lieber Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
ich muss wirklich sagen unsere
Existenzen sind kein Witz was haben wir
hier gerade gesehen also der Kanzler ist
in einer Bürgersprechstunde und
schildert hier gerade das Schicksal
eines Beckers der ihm gesagt hat Mensch
ich habe vor ein paar Jahren noch
ausgerechnet auf einen Gasofen mich
umgestellt ja warum wie kann er denn
darüber jetzt ernsthaft Lachen das ist
doch nicht zum Lachen ich weiß dann
heißt es aus seinem Umfeld ja das war ja
in einem anderen größeren Zusammenhang
und so nein nein er schildert das hier
und er lacht da vollkommen unpassend es
ist ja so die Politik hat uns in
Abhängigkeit geführt von Putins
russengas ein riesiger Fehler ein
schwerer Fehler das ging los und da
Kanzler Schröder Merkel hat das voll
weiter forciert da gibt's noch Bilder
wie sie da irgendwie den gashorn quasi
aufdreht mit den Russen zusammen
Katastrophe wer waren denn Vizekanzler
das war Olaf Scholz deswegen muss man
hier auch sagen eigentlich wäre es
angebracht dass die Menschen die dafür
Verantwortung tragen und ja er ist einer
davon vielleicht nicht unmittelbar in
seinem Verantwortungsbereich aber er war
einer der an vorderster Stelle in der
deutschen Politik mit auch dafür
Verantwortung getragen hat angemessen
wäre eher eine Entschuldigung dafür und
keineswegs dass man so sich jetzt hier
irgendwie noch heiter zeigt bei einem
solchen Thema und es ärgert mich auch
vor einem persönlichen Hintergrund mein
Vater hat vor drei Jahren tatsächlich
auch eine Gasheizung eine neue noch
einbauen lassen für satten fünfstelligen
Betrag jetzt sitzt man da mit dem
Schaden jetzt sagt uns die Politik
wieder ja Wärmepumpe wäre eigentlich
toll wäre dann auch wieder sehr teuer
das macht mich also wirklich ein
bisschen böse wenn ich unseren Kanzler
hier so sehe der ja angetreten ist der
Bundestagswahl mit dem Slogan Respekt
für dich also wo bleibt der Respekt vor
dem Normalbürger an der Stelle wo bleibt
der Respekt vor z.B den Bäcker der jetzt
um seine Existenz kämpft fröscheler wo
bleibt der Respekt vor dem Normalbürger
oder sagen Sie das war nur ein
Fettnäpfchen kann Politiker mal
passieren nein ich sehe das gleiche ja
in der in der Politik was Corona angeht
was uns da vorgesetzt wird teilweise wo
man einfach nur sagen muss ist das
haarsträuben der Unsinn der uns
teilweise von der Politik erklärt wird
oder auch die Tatsache dass wir bis
heute keine vernünftigen Daten haben um
die Pandemie zu oder uns behauptet wird
es würde ausreichend Fallzahlen zu
messen Inzidenzen zu müssen
reproduktionszahlen aber viele andere
Bereiche unseres täglichen Lebens
Wirtschaft Bildung psychosoziale Folgen
was unsere Kinder darunter leiden das
wird uns alles vorenthalten dazu kommen
ja noch auf Corona auf ihren Komplex wir
bleiben einmal bei dem Thema von Herrn
Geißler und ich würde jetzt mal Fragen
hier Herr Friedrich was sagen sie dazu
also Fettnäpfchen oder kann man sagen
darf eigentlich nicht passieren es zeigt
eine gewisse Hybris und eine bisschen
besser ist so eine Echokammer eigentlich
rüberkommen er wollte glaube ich witzig
sein aber ich glaube das Olaf Scholz
jetzt nicht gerade der Sympathiebolzen
schlechthin ist und irgendwie ein
Witzbold ist aber er sieht man mal über
was er lacht anscheinend fakt ist uns
wurde tatsächlich vor Jahren gesagt
Leute baut Gas an der Gas ist viel
umweltfreundlicher und es haben
Millionen Deutsche tatsächlich gemacht
jetzt sind wir diese Abhängigkeit ich
erinnere mich auch noch eine Rede von
sogar Donald Trump vor der UN da hat er
mich gewarnt für diese Abhängigkeit von
den Russen und da hat damals Herr Maas
Heiko Maas in ausgelacht eigentlich und
es ist genauso passiert wie erst
eigentlich gesagt hat und Millionen
Deutsche sitzen jetzt auf diesen teuren
Gasrechnungen wissen nicht wie sie
bezahlen soll und es wird er sich erst
ausspielen im Jahr 2023 und dahingehend
sieht man einfach diese Hybrid diese
Abgehobenheit der Politik die nichts mit
der Realität zu tun haben und ich glaube
das fördert natürlich dann protestwinde
oder unzufriedene Bürger die dann
irgendwelche extremen Parteien wählen
das ist brandgefährlich wenn zu
Demokratie
Sebastian was würdest du dir denn
wünschen einen Entschädigungsfond für
diejenigen die das die den Gasofen
angeschafft haben oder was gibt es da
für dich wo du sagst neben dem Respekt
was die Politik besser machen kann ich
finde es gibt durchaus so was wie
private persönliche Lebensrisiken das
heißt man kann ja auch nicht alles von
Privatpersonen und Privathaushalten
immer fernhalten das ist jetzt eben so
auch in meinem Fall damit mein Vater mit
der Gasheizung sitzen wir jetzt halt
damit da ist jetzt einfach so ich bin
kein Freund immer von dieser ganzen
unverteilung also dass man sagt
irgendwie aus der einen Tasche ziehen
wir es hier raus aus der anderen Tasche
gibt es jetzt mal 300 € energiegeld und
das wieder und das ich möchte eher die
Staatsquote runterfahren ich finde man
sollte bei den Steuern mal entlasten und
ich mit sogenannten diese sogenannten
entlastungspakete das ist immer so eine
Zwangsbeglückung es wäre gut mal die
steuerlastung dazu fahren wäre glaube
ich auch für die Wirtschaft für die
Dynamisierung dieses ganzen Landes
eigentlich der richtige Schritt und das
würde ich mir wünschen aber der Respekt
der fehlt dir ja also wenn Olaf Scholz
sagt Respekt für dich das war ein
relativ respektloser Auftritt den Erde
eingelegt hat sie dieser respektlose
Auftritt da fragt man sich immer sie
sind Politikwissenschaftler und ich
frage mich mal hatte die Politik früher
mehr Respekt haben wir jetzt nur das
Gefühl der Respekt ist weg wie hat sich
das entwickelt früher waren die
Beziehungen zwischen Bürgerschaft und
Politik etwas weiter auseinandergezogen
das Politiker im Bürgersprechstunden
gehen und dass das im Fernsehen oder in
irgendwelchen sozialen Medien übertragen
wurde das war so nicht der Fall wirklich
war die Menge der Situationen in denen
man sich sozusagen nach missverständlich
ausdrücken oder in ein Fettnäpfchen
setzen oder seinen wahren Charakter
wieder eigenes wollen im doch zu
erkennen geben konnte wesentlich
reduzierter da hat sich tatsächlich
unter dem Eindruck von Medien das
politische System verändert ganz
wesentlich ist aber auch zu begreifen
dass die Politik insbesondere die
Spitzenpolitik weithin ein sehr
intüchtiges Geschäft ist man muss
aufeinander reagieren und man muss auf
die Medien über die man ja politik
spielt reagieren das heißt man achtet
sehr darauf welche Themen sind im Moment
gerade anzusprechen auf welche Weise
muss ich welches Thema ansprechen früher
war klar dass es billig und die Russen
haben sogar während des Kalten Krieges
verlässlich geliefert und das ist dann
auch sozusagen nicht so gefährlich wie
die Atomenergie wo ja ständig die
atomweile in die Luft gehen und die Welt
verstrahlen infolgedessen war es damals
ganz üblich zu sagen Freunde setzt auf
Gas inzwischen ist Gas ganz schlecht
weil es ganz teuer ist und es kommt auch
von den Russen und so weiter das heißt
auf das was jeweils gängig ist das was
jetzt jeweils sozusagen erwartet wird um
soziale Prestige Punkte als Politiker zu
gewinnen darauf reagiert man im übrigen
Verweis ich darauf beim Thema
Abgehobenheit oder wir gehen Bürger wie
gehen Politiker mit den Bürgern um
unter hochschullehren sagt man die
Universität wäre schön wenn es keine
Studenten gäbe und der Politikern sagt
man Politik ist schön solange es keine
Wahlen gibt verstehen sie auf
Landesebene wurde die Wahlperiode auf
fünf Jahre anderthalb verlängert mit dem
Argument dann können wir länger
Sacharbeit machen und auf Bundesebene
wird das auch erwogen das heißt damit
man ja den Störfaktor Bürger nicht mehr
so hautnah spürt und das ist schief
gegangen eine politische Klasse ganz
wesentlich um sich selber kreist nicht
darum die Bürger denn wenn die aufhüpfig
werden sind ja bloß Populisten und um
die muss man sich eh nicht kümmern aber
sie haben angesprochen dass es früher
mehr Entfernung gab zwischen Bürger und
der Politik was man aber ja sagen muss
früher waren die Politiker ja gefühlt
näher bei den Bürgern Edmund Stoiber
lebt in der doppelhaushälfte in
Wolfratshausen Frau Merkel hat jetzt
auch nicht in der riesigen Villa gewohnt
also da hat sich Politik doch weiter vom
Bürger entfernt wenn man zum Beispiel an
Jens spahnsvilla denkt oder auch an
andere luxus-sachen naja ich würde
vorschlagen dass jetzt nicht an
einzelnen Wohnobjekten festzumachen wir
nennenswerter Teil von Politikern
insbesondere von Abgeordneten lebt auch
durchaus in ganz normalen Verhältnissen
nein nein es hat eher wirklich damit zu
tun dass sie in den Politikbetrieb immer
auf das reagieren müssen was in dem
Politik Betrieb drinnen ist und seitdem
es diese Schere Kluft ist vielleicht zu
viel gesagt aber diese Entfernung diese
psychische Entfernung der Bürgerschaft
von der Politik gibt und die Politik
sich von der Bürgerschaft eher gestört
empfindet seitdem ist der Fall ist
werden dann Politiker auch sehr linkisch
im Umgang mit Leuten seit wann ist das
konkret der Fall ja das ist seitdem so
Sendungen wie zur Sache Kanzler aus
wahlkampfgründern in der späten
kohlphase erfunden worden sind seitdem
dann Regionalkonferenzen in den Parteien
unumgänglich wurden seitdem Parteitage
durch inszeniert werden und seitdem eine
Bundeskanzlerin namens Merkel das
Erlebnis hatte dass sie einem Mädchen in
einer Fernsehsendung sozusagen
hartherzig kam und die Gewalt dann ihre
vollständige politische Richtung in
Sachen Migration verändert hat an der
Stelle fingen an Politiker zu merken es
kann gefährlich sein mit dem Bürger und
umzugehen und im Zweifelsfall versuche
ich dann denen nach dem Munde zu reden
oder und oder witzig zu sein und wenn
man nun nicht gerade der größte Witzbold
der Republik ist dann geht das schief
wie unlängst bei Kanzler Scholz Herr
Friedrich sind also jetzt
zusammenfassend die Medien eigentlich
schuld weil die zu viel Nähe zur Politik
haben und die Politiker denken jetzt sie
müssen Charismatiker werden
wahrscheinlich auch der Druck der
sozialen Medien ist enorm ne man
versucht halt Klicks zu generieren über
tiktok und Instagram und Social Media
und viele haben sie schon die Finger
verbrannten haben wieder die ganzen
sozialen Plattformen verlassen ne aber
Fakt ist man sieht hat Robert Habeck hat
sich zurückgezogen viele viele natürlich
klar weil die einfach gemerkt haben ist
kreiert dann auch ein Shitstorm
teilweise man geht schnell in
Fettnäpfchen rein aber man sieht halt
auch diese Abgehobenheit tatsächlich und
ich meine früher wenn jemand ein Fehler
gemacht hat ist noch zurückgetreten es
gibt gar nicht mehr ich frage mich immer
wann treten eigentlich Politikerin mal
zurück ne manche Rücktritt ist von der
Sache nicht begründet
manche Rücktritt wäre von der Sache
begründet und das Problem ist dass die
meisten Politiker wegen Kleinigkeiten
zurücktreten ein Bundesinnenminister
trat einmal zurück weil er einem
SPD-Kollegen gesagt hat passt auf macht
den nicht zum Innenminister denn bei dem
Schwert ein Verfahren da musste der
Innenminister zurücktreten bei großen
Sachen wie eine völlig falschen
Energiepolitik oder corona-politik wählt
man nicht die Regierung ab sondern einen
der diese Politik mitgetragen hat wenn
man sogar zum Bundeskanzler
demografische Sprichwort dass ich immer
wieder dann nenne ist nämlich ich glaube
ein Schaf und du wirst gehängt glaube
1.000 Schafe du wirst gefeiert das ist
anscheinend ist das Motto momentan in
Brüssel und in Berlin diese 100.000
Kitas und du wirst und du kannst dich
entschuldigen und sagen ja es war falsch
aber wir sollten keine Schuldzuweisungen
machen wir machen einfach weiter genau
jeder DDR ist das man muss nach vorne
diskutieren keine Fehler Diskussion nach
vorne diskutieren und an dieser Stelle
sind wir gelehrige Schüler und wir sehen
uns vorwärts immer rückwärts immer und
das ist Sozialismus deswegen haben wir
gerade etwas überall zu sehen die
Regierung in ihrem Lauf halten weder
Ochs noch Esel auf und auch so jetzt
haben wir auch hier viele Rezepte
gemacht die letzte Frage zur These von
Sebastian Geister geht natürlich an
Sebastian Geist und das ist die Frage
muss denn jetzt herr Scholz für den Witz
zurücktreten
es waren unglücklicher Auftritt er hätte
das auch nicht sagen sondern ich finde
es hat eine Geisteshaltung offenbar für
an so einer Stelle lachen muss sehr
schwierig sehr schwierig